in the last video we saw that a
geometric progression or a geometric
sequence is just a sequence where each
successive term is the previous term
multiplied by a fixed value and we call
that fixed value the common ratio so for
example in this sequence right over here
each term is the previous term
multiplied by 2. so 2 is our common
ratio and any non-zero value can be our
common ratio can even be a negative
value so for example you could have a
geometric sequence that looks like this
maybe start at one and maybe our common
ratio here is well our common ratio
let's say it's negative three so one
times negative three is negative three
negative three times negative 3 is
positive 9 positive 9 times negative 3
is negative 27 and then negative 27
times negative 3 is positive 81 and you
could keep going on and on and on
what i now want to focus on in this
video is the sum of a geometric
progression or a geometric sequence and
we would call that a geometric series so
let's scroll down a little bit
so now we're going to talk about
geometric geometric
series which is really just the sum of a
geometric sequence so for example an
exam a geometric series would just be a
sum of the sequence so if we just said
one
plus
we do that same color
if we said
1 plus
negative 3 plus 9
plus negative 27 plus 81 and we were to
go on and on and on this would be a
geometric series and we could do it with
this one up here just to really make it
clear of what we're doing so if we said
3 plus 6 plus 12 plus 24 plus 48 this
once again is a geometric series just
the sum of a geometric sequence or a
geometric progression
so how would we represent this in
general terms and maybe using sigma
notation
well we'll start with whatever our first
term is
and over here if we want to speak in
general terms and we could call that
a our first term
so we'll start with our first term
a
and then each successive term that we're
going to add is going to be a times our
common ratio
so and we'll call that common ratio r so
the second term is a times r
then the third term we're just going to
multiply this one times r so it's going
to be a times r squared
a times r squared and then we can keep
going plus a times
r to the third
a times r to the third power and let's
say we're going to do a finite geometric
series so we're not going to just keep
on going forever let's say we keep going
all the way
until we get to let's say we get keep
going all the way until we get to some a
times r to the n
a times
r
to the nth power so how can we represent
this with sigma notation and i encourage
you to pause the video and try it on
your own
well
we could think about it this way
we could think about it this way and
i'll give you a little hint you could
view this term right over here as a
times r to the 0 and let me write it
down so this is a times r to the 0 this
is a times r to the first r squared r
3rd and now the pattern might be
emerging for you so we can write this as
the sum so capital
sigma right over here we can start our
index at zero
so we could say from k equals zero
from k it was in a different color
from k equals zero from k equals 0
all the way
to k equals n
all the way until k equals n
of
a
that same color
of a
times r
i'm having trouble with colors today
a
times
r
to the kth power
to
the k power and so this is using
sigmotation a general way to represent a
geometric series where r
is some
non-zero common ratio it can even be a
negative value